I hear with Hannah Witton noted youtuber
we were just doing a video for your
channel yeah we are building a PC Wow
let's just leave it at that so I thought
it might be fun to whilst we're here
just do a very quick video talking about
books because you are a massive
bibliophile yes I love books for those
that you don't know who you are really
what do you do online I make videos um a
lot about sex and relationships
education and about periods and just
generally breaking down taboo topics and
apparently I also play video games and
now I'm building a PC but not only so
you have your own book club yes and you
also written a book written about very
excitingly today we can talk about how
you are writing a new book
yeah so what are you reading at the
moment I am currently reading inferior
by Angela signee it is about a lot of
science research that's been done into
the differences between men and women
there's maybe there are differences in
them you know so it's a lot of
psychology biology evolutionary biology
it kind of takes you on a history of all
of the research that's been done like
kind of like from Darwin up until like
current research that's been do it being
done and it's a lot about sexism within
the science industry and then also
interestingly how studies are then
portrayed in like the press if there's
like a groundbreaking study what are the
actual study says and then what the
headlines say they're the stuff that the
public learn and often it's quite
different I mean that's it quite
on-brand for you mean how yeah when
you're reading like the books you've
read this year how many are like in your
niche and then how many are yeah well
this one's for banging book club right
which is the book club and podcast where
we talk about books about sex but yeah I
think probably read I read one a month
that is of that at least and then
everything else is just
often like from recommended or my long
list of like to be read that's been
piling up forever and ever
yeah genuine fraud by E Lockhart that is
great and how do you like me now tile by
Holly Bourne so this is a book that has
told backwards and it is why a and it is
about a girl called jewel and it's about
her like friendship with Imogen you
never really gonna meet Imogen you like
who is it because all talk backwards do
you like piecing it all together and is
she who she says she is and right and
then how do you like me now is about a
very something woman who had her like a
best-selling novel and not a novel about
selling memoir in her 20s and is super
famous because of it and now all of her
friends are like settling down and
getting married and having kids and it's
all about kind of like figuring out like
how those pressures from society unlike
and also a lot of stuff about social
media in this and like having just [ __ ]
together like publicly outwardly because
she's also a public figure I'm gonna
have to read this this is hilarious so
another one I've read I don't have a
physical copy because I listen to
inaudible it was beauty queens by Libba
Bray I want to say it was another
banging book club one and it was about a
plane that crashes on a deserted
deserted island and the plane is full of
teen beauty pageant contestants so it's
the Lord of the Flies
but with teen beauty pageant girls and
it is hilarious and it's like a takedown
of the patriarchy of capitalism but it
also has like these mystery elements of
like so like the bad guy is the
corporation and the corporation
basically owns every product ever in
America and also is the company behind
the beauty pageant but also the
corporation are making weapons that
they're selling to this fictional places
meant to be like somewhere
like South Central America and then they
have a secret base that is on the island
where the girls are stranded and it's
like and the and the woman who's like in
charge who's like the Queen Queen Queen
beauty lady who's like all in charge is
like also been wanting to like run to
become president in the United States of
America does your enjoyment of folks
then has that changed now that you've
written one does it change how you've
read books no I think I know I don't
think it's changed I don't know maybe
maybe I like because I write nonfiction
as well so it's a bit different I think
my enjoyment of novels this like still
the same you don't read it in a
different way you're not consciously
like thinking about how or the direction
they've taken I think I only do that for
like individual books if there's
something about the style of a book that
like for instance like this I find it
really interesting in terms of like you
know how did she piece it together like
how does she know like the whole plot
first and then like does she write it in
chronological order like so it's only
like four if the book makes me think
about how it was made that I watch a
film
okay so right we should probably talk
about then we teased it already what is
this new book about it's called the
hormone Diaries I have a web series on
my channel that is about I came off the
pill and documented like getting my
period again after like not having
period for seven years then like
figuring out contraception and and all
of that stuff and yeah it's a book about
everything I've learned over that two
years and then also including a lot of
other people's hormone Diaries then but
one body semi-autobiographical for a
part of it yeah so but it's also like
information and education as well yeah
it's kind of like what you do with a lot
of your videos and that is a
personalized narrative mm-hmm that's
what people attach to you and then also
like yeah and then this is why I've
learned and
XY said by the way did it it and then
and then having other people's Diaries
it's not people that you know personally
know people from my audience I am not
crowd-sourced kind of nonfiction yeah
that's super interesting I mean okay so
the stories are incredible there's so
many like really funny ones and then
like some really heartbreaking I can
imagine yeah yeah I mean why did you
decide to do it as a book rather than
doing I don't know say continuing the
video series or me I would turn that
into something different I feel like
with the video series I'd kind of like
come to a head with my personal journey
in terms of documenting that I
occasionally still make videos with
other people to talk about their stories
if I'm like a topic area that I haven't
covered yet but the reason why I want it
to be a book was that one the whole moon
Diaries the name in itself lends it to
be like a physical thing it's like a
diary and then also one of my favorite
things about doing this series has been
people's comments and people like
sharing their own experiences and so I
just wanted to formalize that anyway
you're using your platform to give them
and also there's like some chapters
though so there's like about periods and
everything to do with that and then
everything to the contraception but then
we've got a whole bit about like when
stuff goes wrong so like two swords or
diseases and infections and like I have
had UTIs but I don't have PCOS I don't
have endometriosis so then having those
stories in for that and then there's
trans stories in there as well it's like
on hormone replacement therapy and that
cuz that's like an entirely separate
experience that I can't really speak on
and then pregnancy I also have never
been pregnant quite a monumental task to
to write something like this yeah so
like how did you do you break it down by
section or like what's your approach
yeah so you saw there was a whiteboard
right so yeah I just know what the
chapters are going to be and then I kind
of like okay periods what is everything
that I know about periods and I'll just
like write down all of these words and
then I just know I want to include all
of that stuff within that section so
it's like
about period products they stuff about
PMS stuff about like the actual bleeding
stuff about like starting a period
including all of that stuff and so like
with contraception it's like okay well
the pill obviously and then like other
hormonal contraception non hormonal ways
it affects your mood ways it affects
your body okay fertility awareness so
you can compartmentalize them yes so I
just kind of like throw out as many
things that I know and associate with
those almost like a marriage to start
writing and see what comes out genuinely
okay I the way I write is that it's word
vomit and then I send it to my editor
and I'm like make something else yeah
have you learned any lessons from doing
the first book yes I learned that I did
it brilliantly friends of mine have
always like who have also written books
say that they've like edit as they go
which is like apparently not how you're
supposed to do it
yeah because then you does like don't
have anything cuz then you're like ah
this like 500 words that you just wrote
you're like no it's terrible and you
just delete it and I'm like I'm not I
won't do that so what I did for my first
book doing it
I literally just like wrote the whole
thing I was just like a little up hmm
and then handed it to them and like I
did a reread of it obviously and like
tidied like some stuff up but I don't
like edit as I go at all that's yeah cuz
I'm a genetic I time yeah and then
you're like constantly like looking for
little things whereas I'm just like no
I'm just gonna like write the whole
thing do one read through one edit and
then hand it off and like see what
feedback come of that
it's around everything off I thought
that I would because I had a talentless
hack I would steal the end of an
interview from inside the Actor's Studio
No okay so basically they do a
quick-fire questionnaire at the end
gives this this like overall assessment
of your personality oh god these are ten
questions no one so first thing that
pops into your head
the first one is what is your favorite
word
first thing that came to my head was poo
I think my favorite word is but it is it
does begin with a pee it's like I love
it's two words porkpie I just love the
way it sounds it feels in the mouth what
is your least favorite word clunge
what's creatively spiritually or
emotionally sort of gets you going plane
plane I always I hate flying but I
always feel like I saw out my whole life
when I'm on a plane journey I like got
out a notebook and I'm like okay I'm
gonna plan
I don't you mean actually that's me in
trains yes right because I'm like I'm
not no internet I don't want to speak to
the person next to me just forces you to
constantly what is the opposite of that
what turns you off and get your and
stops any kind of like juices flowing I
always like sit at my desk when I have
like nothing to do and I'm like stuck in
a rut and I just twiddle my thumbs and
it's like not breaking that thing that
always you yeah like what I need to do
when I get into that it's just go
outside and go for a walk yeah but you
never think to do it yeah but even if
I've got because like being freelance
means like you have like really busy
times then other times when like nothing
really is happening it's even during the
times and nothing is really happening I
sit at my desk nine till five twiddling
with thumbs and that's not helping me
think of something new to do what is
your favorite curse word say anything
yeah that might well be censored what
sound or noise do you love okay this is
gonna sound this is real nish I love the
sound of my stoma farting
to me it's like okay she's walking I
don't think my digestive system is and
it's also really funny
okay what's the opposite what sound a
noise do you hate chalkboard or like
knife on plate like what profession
other than your own attempt what would
you want to try I'd love to try being a
stage actor but I don't think I could
pub we're doing like the same thing
every day for like a year what
profession would you not like to do
doctor or nurse and and that's as a
patient if someone is better like nope I
would never do your doctor day and that
potentially relevant final question if
Heaven exists what would you like to
hear God say when you write at the
pearly gates oh oh I would like him to
say like okay sorry Hannah you were
wrong
Like Heaven does exist but just so you
know everyone else got it wrong too
welcome to the real yeah this is
actually what's really up come in and
have a good time I dunno well thank you
what does that mean about my personality
when we go into cloud you know doing it
is available everywhere there's you know
anyway you can find books and when is
the new one coming out you know 13th of
June 2019 and you can check out Hannah's
channels over your link in the
description and there's a video there
when we try to build a PC you'll be
finished it will be ready okay thank you
very much for watching bye
[Music]